You're supposed to max out the fire
And get food not ExplorerWhat happened.
Imagine
Dragons
?
Period
Build-A-Bear
You can try to defeat the closest KingYes.
So we'll have to.
Save up these cookies
Better put those in there
So I should have been in the rain so no
I'm going to
My horse
Don't know your uncle's on wolves or bears
I don't know I can't drop it allAll right
now you can go talk down trees.
The small ones
In the oil bear
Ing
Today
Remember this
I'm starving goodbye
Song
I'll come get you when it's morning
Stone
Crazy because I was right there
Holy GodI can burp. Look how much I wind up
the map. Look at the map.
Look at the end
I will Scouting Around that's what I got
this crapAnd I have more scraps. Credit
Union.
Imagine if there was a glitch in the game
and you just got to
Hey hey don't
Hey don't grab my stuff all my stuff back
I just played it
And I lost myPhone.
She's like four
I'm on my birthday
Else
Pick it up and bring it to me
Game
You got that you're going with my skin
Come on I can't take it I'll probably
because
Wait I can kill a wolf with two hits
Sorry my off day so
The fire stick
I finally have a badge
?
Grinder
So don'tSpend anything yet.
Funny book
I don't know why people don't forget
We still have another first kid
And it's day 8 and now let'sNot get any kids
for 99 days.
Bieber Little Mermaid I'm trying toDo funny
bunny.
In there
Shut up girl cuz I didn't get to get my
buddies but
How many minutesSo we're going to jump the
guy that shoots.
There's two of them
That's your weapon it electrocutes
That scared me
Cuz I was really close to the fire
Dot dot is something getting more security
right nowWe need more food.
I want you to go get the first kid
Wait for me
To my rifle
Don't just use your drivingI'm in Europe.
Jesus.
A bandage really
Die
Again
So you're going to come out and help meNot
today.
The kids in there
Get free foods
I swear to God if you take my students
Turn off your screen
ShotStill no money but okay.
Mountains
The chair
And make sure tracks and your tracks don't
go away so like if I go all the way to the
end
I can justWalk on my tracks and the fire
goes out.
You can see how much the fire has
The first complete you can put it in the
blank
We need a compassAnd a boost pad. Enough. We
need a light.
How to get more wood
We have 35
Bring your time
I accidentally
We need foodI'm going to go get a shoe.
Your Alpha pal is under your BattlefieldGrab
it.
One word for me one
That was hard work there's two mammoths by
his Workshop too I'm sorry
Look how much stuff is in my inventory I
won't make it in time
Period
Star Wars staying home todayTomorrow.
I gave the I gave the their help to the
Trader the other game
Mommy did that to her back while my head was
laying on her back
So get more woodWe're going to go get more
scrap tomorrow.
No that's scared me when he popped up all I
saw was the red and the lights oh my God bro
I was thinking like what did I say I was
supposed to say oh no before that I said
something I was saying something important
Okay I'm going to go find a mammoth?.
What is my cup
Finally I won't be stuck
I put both of them in thereOne.
Why when you do the the people one by one
Already have a strong flashlightYou like
myself little kids.
ThatThat was me because it filled up all the
way.
I don't know
Myself
Oh now you want to give me a good ax really
I hate this gameYou know all right.
Once
You dieWow.
Oh really I got a good I got a break nobody
needs youYou got a great job.
Come back
Would you buyIt.
Once I feel like we're here come over cuz
why you want to sit here and do that
Why you do that
Go next to the other day are you slow
ByeNo just drop it.
No that's my bed I deal with itThat's the
difference.
You can't do itI can't do the other part.
Again any more blood too
This morning
Ribs for you because you actually put
something or something
I want to go get some presents everybody
I have more advantages than you
How much do you have five
Or she go don't forget to go to the
gingerbread Village
I had a cake
I'm going in the gingerbread house
We'll go to the get that Mamas and the
morning
Okay come on hurry up bye
Here's about that I can't find the fireBall.
Oh my god dude don't need it
I have to itMute. Do you want me.
To make my phone
Let me make my stew I'm not even more and
then we can make your cakes
On the floorI'm mixing one cake.
Downstairs
Batman
Elf it's magic
Ian
Yo yo yo get it
Now I have two ribs
Accidentally news
We know I wasn't supposed to drop my
paintbrush
WellLooks like we can't. Yeah.
But I'm going to go cookies
816No.
No I almost put my steak my face in the
truck I know
So make yourself and then make my I'mma make
my show so let's separate our bed so give me
the
I can just wait
I'm going to make my roomAnd that's where
our stuff's going to be.
My my love is going to be right hereActually
it's going to be by a rock.
No it's not complete
But that's not it I forgot about it
But I can't
I want some hairI got two shows for me.
To Blue Print on the floorFor you.
Actually online
I'll try to find another man
The name
I still haven't used my own reborn to get
scratch
That's why we're leaving
We're going to get scrapped just in case we
getIn case we get jumped.
Okay
You got a good song
Don't know what I got but we're not like you
got oh no you got that thing boy however to
upgrade myself
But three are protect you one
BroAnimals.
Now we're playing the gameWe're too occupied
to do that. Some food.
Will come over with his friend atAnd you.
Get oneOh yeah he doesn't need it yes he
does go put it in their room.
You sharing the room with a girl
I got the slide back
Girl
Or is it just mean
No not yet today
Please
I'll make the kitchen
Hey this is myBut some of it.
Unes3 and 3 to put in that.
I'm going to eat a cakeOn one.
Another one
Yes ma'am
It's cuz the tablet kept falling in a
creative short
I forever have beef with that iPad now
because that was that's a great charger
Pump It Up
Now
Where you atBye bye you're not see my life.
There's another there's more people
?
How are youTomorrow.
Make the kitchen
So we're going to make that and put a bunch
of wood in it so make it too
And then make allPerfect.
Behind here
NowPick it up and let me do it.
If you need the hammer handleIt.
You can put this up
Bye
Let's go find me all the kids
The third cake
Ariel I know all of them there's wolves in
the first one second I'm at two bears and
then this is not too bad
Wait we can just talk to one then
Until the day we can talk to you tomorrow
We need more foodSpecial for men tomorrow.
And then we'll go tomorrow get up there or
we can just get the two bears tomorrow
No I can Amendment tomorrow and then
Have this and how your dayI have a bunch of
presents.
You know I can't get themFound it.
NiceBoyfriend.
I literally ran out like 2 seconds ago
They play for
Them
Hey Google
We're going the wrong way
Man help me
You die
Come up here come up here
Making you turnAround.
Here tonight
?
Don't jump get down here
Look it's Rudolph
Cuz he's a deerI think I know why he did
that to work.
Why he made this game why because when it's
Christmas time he can't it's a deer leaving
voiceover
Call my rifle until
I see a piece of cake
Thank youAnd I need an awful.
Please please please I need the speed my
mom's kind of homeless butReally.
So I can take it
They played in our faces they play real bad
The whole time I saw you had a good act but
you didn'tRecord you thought I had a good
idea.
You play I'm less phone nowCome on.
Cuz we're not supposed to stay out
lateThat's scary. I need to run these three
laps so I'm going to.
Get a girlfriend
I got an Orwell BarrelComing out to get.
You're going to die.
I'll meet you
I don't care about that
I just kill myself
If I die remember this
Please ArielI hope period you got this.
You got this just scary
You're one bullet
Period
Come around me
Be glad I still have them cuz I used like I
used three
Yeah girlSorry.
Meet again Alpha World fireThat's awesome
thanks for. What should I get. Should you
get.
About time about time yeah
LOL
No no no no
Hurry up so you can come move this man out
of my room
That's crazyShe got to go.
PerfectI'll ask you what you make money.
I don't have to run skinIt is awesome.
Monday 54Or did you pass 96 days.
Come home
No rabbit I want to get jumpedBy a little
wolf. By a little one.
I have one more day before
Come back and move the school again out of
my room
This all of it
So we got the next fire which is mine too
I thought
Well when he comes next song
YouTube now
Make sure
We're sorry did you put in it
It's getting tooken by Vic now
LookAt mine.
I just did
Or Amanda's turn to
Last night go get some more
So we're I have one who has two kids and who
has one kid
I get that's not there
I'm going to put it in there now
Hey Ariel
That's the last bedtime
Story
Really they don't love you
No firstI'm going to go.
Buy me again I will rip your hair off
Wait isn't it
All right I made it yesterday
Wait I'm
One
You you know she got to make some noodles
she lost oh we're going to attack tonight
California shut up
Hurry up
Jump the gun Depot
To answer
Alright
It's on 5 minutes because
Be quiet
Then blowing Ashlyn
Who miss youMiss you I have barbed wire we
just need to get the people done.
These peopleThe electricity.
Dropped their weapons
Play for real
At least we're on Day 72
Yeah but she lost the sign no dying
challenge
Please
Yes please
Assassin's nameBut it's not enough do they
both of us.
Okay so I thought a bunch of trees from you
So much damage
Why didn't you move out the way
I triedFighting. There.
So it slowed me down so I couldn'tAgain.
You're not the Explorer because I was barely
any food on my shelf
So there's no school on the Shelf
?
I don't know how farThey've only till I'm
not trying to do that.
Okay
Perfect
Well Riley have you played a scary thing
yesterday if you want oh my God but then
Who do I
You're not getting on itOh yeah and upstairs
there is.
WhatThere is a football.
You're not taking moneyI think there's a
good. Of this.
I know that
When I drop my dog
Hey Google
Google
We didn't smell fashion shut up please
I'm talking to youWho else am I talking to
Casper.
No don't do it Road
Want to play scary game Ariel
Frozen skin
Actually using my neck hurt
Get upNo because I can't find it.
Yeah I don't like it
I don't like it
What game
That's scaryWhat.
What
Okay
What's it calledShut up.
Don't listen
That was no no
Funny
Cash for fun to play a scary game if you get
scared to close your eyes
I was so good
Peppa
PigIt's been promoting.
Where are you who's that
Why is there a McDonald's signJust upside
down.
Oh and right I think I seen someone to play
this is some things leaking do not look up
On YouTube it's something's leaking from the
feeling never look up
Here you goThank you. What.
Then blow itCash blow it.
I do not hear anything from that TVLook
around I have $150.
Thank you
It was on the fridge
All right can you make more meat
Or out of it
On the windowHe's on the fridge.
What
Oh he's singing doomers that's why
So you don't like all the questions
I'm not just checking it back
Check the camerasWhen I.
Where's the cameras
We were supposed to close it there's a face
on the back of his head
Okay
NothingInteresting activity. I left.
And went outside
No name
In love
I carry I'm sorry all right remember this
I finished
I'm playing
That I finished it no no
Please leave
Because it's not fair
Especially how you giving birth
No but you're actually weird
Get your elbow
And all my clothes are mine I want them back
I want my stuff
Finally to be the baby
All right
How do you spell edges
All right I have an engine
ItI'm not.
OkaySo cute.
Getting a stroller
I really don't see it
It's time
Like a sleep
Hey I'm going to tell you where to go turn
This way
We're living at your house
Pull it off of me
I'm not a cheating again
Episode
Like this
Song
DecemberBelieve.
No
Ah
Play around come here
Ali come here I didn't hear youCall me.
Please
Let's see that his birthday is what happened
All right I remember this
I remember this game
I want my money
Okay
Go back up Nikki
What's
What are you doing
We need to get my cop my uniform today
Tomorrow
Morning ready
Associated location directions
He said that she will never lose money she
already transfers
$50 gift card with one
One I see me
I'm looking Professor yet I know she's not
running
Yeah
See that you already help you
Because
Hey Google hey Google
You're gone
Wait
Do you want this weekend
We are here today
All
Please change your battery
Are they my parents are already back okay
Buck
Both
Send
This time to get him out
For 15 minutes
Listen
Hey baby
Office
The person that is in here God sounded
Sorry babe
What what is thisFuck.
And why do we need a second place
A baby
They told me that peopleS.
?
Did you see that
Bye
He said I needed to make a chicken before we
can eat it
Don't hear this
Inside
Scary
Where's my location
Yes it is translate from
I'm already gone
Sometimes this evening
MaLays.
Ia 20
I really hope that guy oh my God
I can't believe it I said that longWithout a
dinner.
Okay I got a money for free no money for you
The last time we need to have a buddyKids.
Hello Kitty person go back to the fire so
I got to feel chemistry
I have two tickets
And I have another fuel canisterFive for
five give me another.
Give me another fuel canister I got a
bandageAsk for fuel canisters.
Bye
Oh nice wake me up
Don't want to take him 13 hits I'm getting a
ladder
Leaving movies I've seen here stay over
there and I swear to God if there's going to
get your name
Thank you
Not right there's there's a literally
Ariel why can't I turn
First tryThank you.
Help me helpWell I'm going to build a water.
Cuz I have 20 of them
Nothing
Where are you
I'm a little cry
A lot ofHelp. Did you give me a bunny.
Story
You don't need to kill it
Cuz it's in the park
Er
?
Where's the school again
Can come down and out
He pushed meThank you.
All right I got a new information all where
are you
Inside
My face
I'm so glad I got this
Oh myOmar. Cause I know that.
I'm going to blow ParkI can't even find
myself some food.
How do you die
Last night
Come get meYou want me to cook you. Know.
My name
Predict this is going to be scrapped cuz
we're already on level four
I'll be back I'm going to go get some
chicken
Owen Owen
I found the church come here
I don't knowMan me and say John from the
church on the first day.
Okay
I'm getting my shirt off
The moon Morning Star
Okay you get bandagesDid it too.
MuchIf you finish.
Another leather body
Alcohol?
I'll go get some kids yo whatI will get
lucky.
Well I will jump
Just pick up some stuff that isn't cooked
and I'll cook it for you
Another bandage
Just in case you or I die
Awesome music I found the culture
Get the red one
Direction
No no no
McDonald's
Does it wrong thing
Hello person
I don't know I don't know if he's taking you
out somewhere over
But I'm telling youNo. Yes.
Here's your face man
I don't know if you're going to
So y'all need to be ready
With you though
I ate all the ice cream
Ear
Turn on the busBefore I left. Turn it off.
On turn it off.
Bye
Send
It's always in it feels
We're not into that they said they were
supposed to be here on Sunday
S
You feeling neglected